my name is Curtis Simmons I'm a
thirty-year-old combat veteran now I
work for a security company
protecting marijuana farm you know you
leave war but war never really leaves
you
everybody has their demons you know I've
got PTSD insomnia depression when I got
out of the military I was on nine
different prescriptions I couldn't even
say what they all work you know so
messed up finding this type of work to
where I'm actually working with a
medical plant that helps you know taking
care of those symptoms that I have and
thousands of other veterans have people
kind of still shunt upon it because it's
you know it's federally illegal so they
say oh they're just a bunch of combat
veterans that just smoke weed but it's
more than that
it goes back to that that camaraderie
that Brotherhood I'll take a steak
dinner that's cool they understand us we
understand each other it's a lot more
comforting to find that within your own
ranks within your own company you know
you're not really worried about who you
can and can't talk to because all we've
all lived it we've all seen it I went
through a little bad time of my life
after my four deployments in Iraq I
actually I put a gun to my head and
luckily one of my buddies was there to
talk you down Colorado there's been
several instances of attempted robberies
burglaries things like that so we apply
these fundamentals out here on the range
to shoot in those confined spaces under
stress and in a quick time turn around
because seconds matter in a gunfight
guys that have similar experiences to us
guys that have been to Afghanistan in
Iraq they kind of come back with the
skill set that it takes to really you
know protect marijuana and keep things
safe
most days get off work to go home and
relax a little bit and this is how I do
that
we both we've been through a lot of
combat some multiple of different things
anxiety stress it helps calm my stomach
so I can eat better relax and then with
the anxiety like we were talking about
earlier anxiety and stress it just kind
of relaxes and blows it away this is a
picture that I took right at the end of
our last appointment together my
symptoms of PTSD were more related to to
anger lack of understanding and
aggression and I think that those things
all stemmed from our were a byproduct of
viewing war as a romantic activity and
it's just simply not I went to
Afghanistan with the intent to make a
difference in Afghanistan I left
Afghanistan with an understanding that
the only difference that I could make
was between myself and the guys that I
served with
you